bonjour nicolas bonjour comment allez
vous j'espère bien on va analyser la
gestion de la crise actuelle par le
gouvernement compense et vous comment
peut-on analyser cette crise actuelle en
tout cas et c'est ces restrictions qui
n'en finissent pas nicolas bas on va
essayer d'analyser ça ce matin alors
l'état l'état mais que fait l'état chars
magali voilà la question qui est sur
toutes les lèvres des éditorialistes et
même de certains ministres depuis un an
eh bien l'état finalement il a bien
mauvaise mine et il semble totalement
perdu il n'y a qu'à voir la chienlit la
pétaudière avait les masques et
respirateurs les tests des lits de
réanimation et maintenant et maintenant
les vaccins alors on tournicote on
déclare mon déclarant suppute 1 à saint
denis au plus haut sommet de l'état
c'est la grosse pagaille alors la haute
administration s'enlise dans ces
dossiers les cabinets de conseil privé
n'y retrouve plus leur petit et l'union
européenne est en train de faire
naufrage du côté des côtes belges
s'emparer de la technocratie française
en totale déroute d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
ce les réseaux sociaux des petits malins
ont publié quelques jours un
photomontage de l'elysée sur pour
surplomber pardon parle enseigne
monsieur bricolage
malheureusement nous n'en sommes pas
très loin car même pour nous pondre une
énième attestation français il a fallu
s'y reprendre à deux fois en pleine nuit
et dans la précipitation magali et
nicolas l etat est ce qu'il est à la
hauteur pour nous sortir enfin de cette
crise sanitaire alors vaste question
charlie il va il faut le dire à
l'attitude du gouvernement à gérer cette
crise devient de plus en plus
inquiétante et même à la fois à la fois
déroutante
alors ce matin on va se poser cette
passionnante question peut-on espérer le
retour de l'état nation après 40 ans de
liquidation démocratique économique et
politique
eh bien il va falloir parce qu'avec le
kobe de 19 la mondialisation post
démocratique et viennent de prendre
sacré coup sur la cafetière made in
china bien sûr et on voit très
clairement que les états souverains
comme les usa la grande bretagne la
russie encore israël sont très en avance
finalement sur l'union européenne dans
la luttre contre le coc vie 19 pourquoi
et bien parce qu'ils ne sont pas
tributaires des instances médicales
prat nationale qui décide pour nous ils
ne sont pas ces petits moineaux
européens qui attendent la becquée
vaccinale jeté par notre mutti à tous la
pimpante union européenne et sa radieuse
ursula von der leyen
car ces états il décide il tranché is
appliquent leurs propres stratégies
sanitaires et ça commence à faire des
émules en europe avec certains pays qui
font qu'à vielle cavalier seul car ils
n'ont jamais perdu de vue que l'état
nation est un modèle indispensable qui a
su traverser bien entendu les siècles
à force de coib de légitimité et de
consensus rappelez vous un east renan
qui écrivait que la nation est un
plébiscite de tous les jours et bien là
c'est l'amateurisme permanent avec son
lot de boulettes d'approximations et de
conférences de presse totalement
barbante car pour plaire aux menées au
légalisme banque ces lois je vous le dis
à chaque fois l'état s'est institué
comme nettoyeur de ses capacités
industrielles sanitaires sociales
économiques depuis 40 ans si en fait
l'auto liquidation de l'état deux
exemples pourra pour dire ça en 2009 les
stocks stratégiques de l'état était de
723 millions de masques effet fait le
jeu pas bien tu des masques d'après une
note écoutez bien de la direction
générale de la santé la fameuse dgs de
février 2011
les stocks de l'état était de 600
millions de masques ffp2 et de 800
millions de masques chirurgicaux en juin
2020 olivier derand notre cher ministre
de la santé nous des caribous toi
benoîtement que l'état disposait d'un
stock de 150 millions de masques
chirurgicaux et d'aucuns stocks de
masques ffp2 alors on va se poser la
question forcément elle vient nous cette
question pourquoi cette diminution
brutale de notre stock stratégique qui
n'a pas été renouvelé
eh bien il faut aller relire en rapport
du sénat 2015 vous savez que j'aime
beaucoup lire pour trouver une réponse
une justification et je cite dans ce
rapport je suis allé chercher ça je cite
donc du point de vue des finances
publiques cela permettrait de réaliser
des économies considérables en termes de
coûts d'achat et de stockage
finalement ce qu'on peut voir ce qu'on
comprend c'est que tous les
gouvernements successifs ont donc poussé
à l'économique au risque de se retrouver
en pénurie et donc des dépenses en
dépendant sévères en cas de crise et
bingo bingo
le coc vie 19 est arrivé et nous voilà
nus comme des vers rouler en boule sur
nos côtes le canapé en attendant
l'homélie hebdomadaire de 5 castex et
l'état dépense maintenant des milliards
qui n'a pas pour sauver la maison avec
le quoi qu'il en coûte qui finalement va
nous coûter très cher deuxième exemple
il est extrêmement intéressant on n'en
parle pas beaucoup finalement dans les
médias c'est l'histoire du doliprane
vous savez en france de l'épreuve est
l'un des médicaments les plus prescrits
et rappelez-vous la téméraire agnès
buzyn qui conseillait le un doliprane et
au lit mais manque de pot pour pour nous
le paracétamol est fabriqué en chine et
en inde
et maintenant mon cher chez lipp
souhaite contrôler la production en
france d'ici trois ans eli bin si elles
sont aussi performants tels doliprane
qu'avec bridgestone et bosh
on a encore le temps d'avoir des
migraines la crise sanitaire alors sadr
est elle le retour de l'état nation
selon vous bien sûr allez je veux faire
cadeau de citations formidable que j'ai
trouvé et je vais commencer par jean
jaurès qui nous disait à celui qui n'a
plus rien la patrie est son seul bien
mais je vais citer également clément
bonne super secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes le 30 décembre
dernier chez nos confrères de france
info et je cite les bonbonnes le charme
de la frontière de la souveraineté
nationale i c'est une fable est une
illusion et c'est un mensonge de fin de
citation et bien chanter man l'impéritie
du gouvernement nous sortir de la crise
la crise n'est plus une illusion l'idée
que la stratégie du fédéralisme européen
nous rendre à la liberté est une fable
et professer que l'état nation est un
nationalisme peu mal placé est un
mensonge car l'état nation est
aujourd'hui la meilleure organisation
politique pour retrouver une vie normale
nous donner les moyens de décider par
nous mêmes et de produire sur notre sol
finalement bien que d'une élite
politique maggie biberonné la
mondialisation pause démocratique nous
n'en prenons pas le chemin
emmanuel macron d'annoncer il ya
quelques jours la naissance de
l'association pour une renaissance
européenne en vue de 2022
et comme le disait pour terminer ce cher
aussi jean pierre raffarin la route est
droite mais la pente est forte et si en
plus de ça il faut une attestation un
masque un doliprane programme paix et
ben franchement on n'est pas rendus du
tout à nicolas peut-être votre réaction
par rapport à l'actualité de ces
derniers
notamment la candidature de xavier
bertrand la prochaine présidentielle un
candidat pour les ouvriers dit-il qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
ben c'est le jeu de la présidentielle
qui se remet en route bien entendu il
avait bertrand ça fait un moment qu'il
est tapi dans l'ombre des arbres de la
politique et de cette présidentielle
on voit bien que la droite on a
l'affairé dite la semaine dernière où il
ya deux semaines la droite ne prend pas
en compte effectivement ce qui est en
train de se passer en france elle est
tournée elle est tournée vers la
présidentielle
on se retrouve ainsi une saison
catastrophique sanitaire le sait je les
dis déroutant d'une politique déroutante
et la droite commença à avoir ces
candidats chacun se présentent chacun se
dit mais finalement où sont les
programmes
alors moi je veux bien le candidat des
oubliés mais vous savez où vous savez ce
que j'en pense à mon andré tant que la
droite ne sortira pas de cette
orthodoxie ordolibérale finalement
tournés vers bruxelles
ça va être compliqué pour eux d'ailleurs
on va voir on voir ce qui va se passer
et regardez d'ailleurs les transfuges
des républicains verts emmanuel macron
notamment bruno le maire et toute une
série de gens qui sont ralliés emmanuel
macron parce qu'il n'ya pas l'espace
d'un papier à cigarette entre ces gens
tous ces gens dont tu te une idéologie
européiste ils ne sont pas la
souveraineté d'ailleurs aussi part de
souveraineté européenne pour certains
ils sont tournés vers bruxelles et la
candidature et xavier bertrand bon c'est
un épiphénomène
on verra bien ça va se tirer dans les
pattes au niveau des républicains site à
peu près évident tout le monde
église de ses couteaux électoraux et
politique les jeux de pouvoir vaut se
mettre en place mais la réalité c'est
que la cisaille bertrand et le candidat
la fin des oubliés pour l'instant ça va
être compliqué parce que la france des
oubliés est en train d'avoir mal de près
d'être compliquée dans sa vie de tous
les jours et bien entendu on a
l'impression quand même que ces gens
sont tournés vers la présidentielle et à
mon nom mais n'apportent aucune solution
d'ailleurs on notera que l'opposition
emmanuel macron qu'elle vienne de gauche
qu'elles viennent de droite
aujourd'hui elle est bien mollassonne
notamment quand le parlement a été
totalement excommunié de décision suite
à l'état d'urgence sanitaire la
prolongation du talent d'un jeune du ter
donc ça veut dire que je pense que
finalement ces jeux de partie ces jeux
de pouvoir ses déclarations à
l'emporte-pièce d'une
présidentialisation elles sont
compliquées pour les français et je suis
pas persuadé olivier qu'aujourd'hui ce
sera la véritable urgence de co2
commencé à agiter son petit fanion pour
en tout cas cette france des oubliés
tous les candidats en joue bien
évidemment puisque ils sont toujours les
grands oubliés de cette crise sanitaire
on la vit avec le le gouvernement ces
gens qui étaient en première ligne ces
gens de deuxième ligne qui étaient en
première ligne pendant la crise
sanitaire
on va en parler puisque des gilet jaune
d'ailleurs son fonds sont jugés pour la
participation présumée bien évidemment
au saccage de l'arc de triomphe
c'est gilet jaune cette cause des gilet
jaune elle et elle est complètement en
dehors des débats actuellement nicolas
ben bien entendu aujourd'hui la crise
élitaire peut pas manifester donc c'est
compliqué mais effectivement les gilet
jaune ces litiges de dit souvent c'est
la première pierre à l'édifice de la
cotation populaire je le dis tout le
temps si les gilet jaune c'est ce qu'ils
ont pris conscience qu'on est dépossédé
de leur raison d'être
qu'on les a sortis exclus de la nation
de la façon de considérer l'état nation
comme souverain aussi et si j'ai les
gens ils ont peu d'histoire une mission
de toujours là mais ils sont toujours en
dormance on va dire pour employer un mot
barbare ils sont toujours là la
constestation sociale est toujours là la
question qui se pose centrale
fondamental c'est à dire qu'à la lumière
de la crise sanitaire ducobu 19
est ce qu'il y aura vous savez cette
fameuse convergence des luttes peut-être
regarder les artistes aujourd'hui qu'une
de 75 ciaccio croissant occupé
d'ailleurs ils ont été délogés hier à
bordeaux mais je dirai ce qu'il pourrait
y avoir une convergence des luttes on va
voir cette crise inter et crise
économique tout le monde le dit il va y
avoir quand l'état va débrancher les
aides sociales ça va être une
catastrophe il va ça va être un carnage
absolu socialement politiquement
et puis une nouvelle fois ce qui est
intéressant chez les jets les jeunes
c'est que la souveraineté elle ne se
départit jamais de la cause sociale la
démocratie est la cause sociale
finalement sont extrêmement un briquet
et c'est d'une intimité national de la
nation et les gilet jaune ça et il
démarre c'était le début de sa
finalement de ces gens-là dix mille fois
qu'ils se sont retrouvés loin des
grandes métropoles qui ont été oubliés
qui n'ont pas eu du tout la parole dans
les grands médias
d'ailleurs rtl a beaucoup beaucoup parlé
et mais là dessus je crois pas
aujourd'hui qui emmanuel macron y
compris un dernier point très important
qui a fait tourner la france pendant le
premier confinement qui la fait tourner
ce sont les gilet jaune
ce sont les caristes les magasiniers les
caissières les lecteurs routier c'est
cette france où le périphérique ça te
france oubliée qui a fait tourner la
france qui a tenu la france à bout de
bois ça c'est vraiment l'âme de la
france et par contre va tout la
catégorie des 4 supérieur plutôt
favorable à emmanuel macron et l'argent
mais pour preuve d'excellents livres le
gérant scène marie sur le bloc élitaire
le bloc populaire finalement scellé
gilet jaune et plus largement la france
qui bosse à la france qui travaille qui
a tenu ce pays pendant de longues
semaines pour continuer à le faire
bosser et à le faire tourner donc je
crois qu'on a on a beaucoup parlé des
soignants et à juste titre était normal
mais on a aussi très peu parlé
finalement de cette france là il est j'y
des jeunes en sont issus bien entendu
donc nous verrons ce qui se passera dans
les prochains jours et dans les
prochaines semaines mais la contestation
sociale va revenir
regardez le nombre de plans de
licenciements en regarder l'accueil qui
a eu and i espagne et une hache et à
rodez il ya quelques jours pour les
licenciements super la fermeture de
l'usiné bosch
on voit bien que la tension sociale est
là et aujourd'hui j'en parle dans cet
édito tant qu'on ne reviendra pas l'état
nation l'état souverain l'état
protecteur
finalement et qu'on va laisser la france
ouvert aux quatre vents et pourra
continuer à entendre les injonctions
attendre les injonctions de bruxelles
pour les vaccins pour la rigueur
budgétaire que finalement on appelle
plus l'austérité parce que c'est
l'austérité est bien très sincèrement la
contestation sociale va continuer à
monter et il faudrait éviter que nous
élites politiques continuent à jouer le
feu on parle d' emmanuel macron on
parlera des vies bertrand on peut parler
bruno retailleau
parce que finalement cette espèce de
classe politique néo libérale néo
libérale isabelle sa libération apl sa
néo libérale dirige forcément et 30 des
mesures contre le peuple est là reste
l'assurance de réformes chômage la
réforme chômage de surenchère pardon et
la réforme des retraites va jouer comme
un accélérateur déclassement social
populaire très fort on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler avec vous merci beaucoup
nicolas l'édito de nicolas vidal
trouver tous les jeudis matin dans la
matinale de rtl france